all right welcome to an addition of a
beginner breakdown Amy host Mike kamar
dard we open up to the YouTube comments
today all right we got one from a grills
420 here he says how easy was the 1998
scholastic tournament alright so let's
check it out alright alright so this was
1998 I had the black pieces against a
Chris Brown here all right and then
scholastic chest there's a lot of
slamming of the pieces so so I teach you
guys when to slam the pieces when not to
slam the piece is okay and maybe even
how to trash talk alright so here we go
so he starts out efore he was rated 1100
I was rated 1661 at the time black plays
c5 so Bishop to b5 not very good alright
Bishop in my opponent's territory not
really attacking anything how should we
go about attacking it anybody got any
suggestions yes and why not a 6 right
not all right and we wouldn't slam that
move and then he plays the worst move
all right it gets my day off to a pretty
easy start and this is a move you can
just go ahead and slam all right what
movie all right Kevin slammed it on the
board b5 it's like there's no coming
back from this all right so so he takes
I take there's no need to slam when you
take the bishop he fell for the trap it
was really wasn't much of a trap I just
attacked it and he went the wrong way so
that's a very common way to do with the
bishop not so it so much in that
position but it gets trapped like that a
lot so so be wary of that all right so
night attacks the pawn you can just push
it so it goes back
go back to be one if probably probably
should just go go here kind of keep a
centralized just going backwards isn't
making much progress so attack the pond
and now d-3 all right notice that this
pond is in a pin here right because if
he moves it let's say he moves it then
I'll take okay but do we really want to
move our f pawn here to try to entice
them to take it the answer is no we
don't really want to ever be moving our
F pun because look he would have fallen
for our trap but would move does white
plain out to regain a lot of momentum
here Queen h5 check all right that's why
it's very risky to be moving that F pawn
in the opening cuz take take don't even
take the rook just go for checkmate okay
alright so we just want to leave that
alone and we'll just get our other
bishop out here okay so night up bishop
up gets us netted oh so we're getting
our pieces out we're playing good get
castled and now we can just try to trade
pieces because we're up material we'll
just try to trade Saudi five so he
attacks or night okay so he just
attacked our night the simplest solution
is just move the night we don't need to
go about like making threats you know
that are equal or greater than his and
this is actually worse if we would try
to push our pond here because he would
take our Nate we take his night but then
he get our bishop okay and then okay and
then we would take with check alright
alright fine we'll take it all the way
through then mari alright so so take
take fish pawn takes now we get check
okay
and then he'll take and then you want to
take our this pawn then well ers is
going to take the rook yeah it's a so it
luckily it's black the move so he'll
take and you see how now I have one two
three four five six pawns and he also
has six pawns and we each have five
pieces okay so we went from being up a
bishop even though we got that check in
it really didn't work out too well for
us okay so you know with people just
attack you just do the simple solution
retreat okay i know it's now fun but
sometimes you just have to do it alright
so takes Knight back so we can just
offer more trades here because we're
winning so all trades are good Bishop up
so now he attacks or a night but now we
can go ahead and take the night because
if you would take or night how would we
take back with the bishop and we'd still
maintain our peace advantage excellent
okay alright so he takes Knight back so
now Bishop takes pawn okay so he's
feeling good but not what move can you
go ahead and slam here even if it's not
the best move on the board you can still
go ahead and slam it so kevin says
quietly like what not up to anything
here so the bishop is attacked but what
else is is attacked here threatening
checkmate Queen takes g-tube checkmate
this actually according to the computer
is not the best move he says the best
the computer says the best move is
Bishop takes and then after King takes
then you get the check but I don't agree
with it alright so Queen threads may and
the bishop so what is a great move for
wait to not drop a piece and more
importantly not get checkmated here so
anywhere anywhere we move the rook
unfortunately checkmate so we have to
deal with that checkmate first and
foremost Queen f3 excellent so queen of
three well obviously protects g2 and
then it's attacking this Bishop through
an x-ray so after a queen takes bishop
Queen takes pawn takes and so now Chris
gets an idea instead of just taking the
pawn but you probably shoot up and
eliminating that threat he decides I'm
going to put that pawn in up him when he
moves the wrong rook here he moves this
rook all right so what what move do I
have which probably isn't the best the
best move probably is just flat-out c2
and just have a passed pawn okay but I
decided I'm going to just take forking
the rooks because you see if he takes my
queen I get my queen right back plus a
rook with chuckie but not so it's it's
fantastic alright so so when he takes
his just take back okay and so my queen
is hanging so I should move by queen but
I'm like one of those guys that like you
like I want to make a threat greater or
equal than this so he's threatening my
queen right so I so so there's two
pieces of mind that can thread the enemy
queen this rook and this rook rich rook
should i attack the Queen width if
that's really what I want to do right
Queen to d4 that that yeah yeah instead
I try look a to be eight not
brooke f or else if i play rook f to be
aight i lose a piece because he'll just
come down and take my rook with Jack
excellent and then when i take he'll
take and now look he's got two rooks and
i got a rook in the night so i'm not
doing very well so luckily i put played
the rook a to be eight so when he takes
it what I don't what move do you think I
plan don't take this Queen back right
away I have an in-between move here quit
takes f to do I just want to just say
forget I don't want to be state champion
this year how about Queen takes c1 check
and then rook takes rook takes all right
so now he's he's getting behind the pawn
so now I just bring my night over and I
have ideas to trap the King behind here
first but then I get bored with that
idea and decided I I'm going to win this
polling as fast as i can so i get behind
the pond luckily plays d 4 which makes
this next move almost pretty obvious
yeah or a knight to c6 the fork so take
with check King be three night attacks
the rook rook here so so how do I go
about winning here
the night to see if I Mario beach into
the Punjab night to see Five check goes
there I take with the night and he plays
King to be five and then what move do I
play to make him resign here night to
see seven check so King up do I want to
trade rooks in this position the answer
is obvious yes and then take take and
then just to be funny and play f6
because it's like I can play it now I'm
so goodbye playoff five and games over
I'm just going to read my king up and
eat all these poems get four queens and
and live the life so I'm 10 going into
round two and in round two I get paired
against the freshman sensation Anthony
burek alright so tough game here so I
had the the white pieces here and it was
a good one so II for c6 d4 d5 this is
daya karo con Knight c3 I do not play
the care okay I'm like I played it in
this game okay this so if you're like oh
just play the caro-kann against comer he
doesn't know how to play against that
please be my guest okay I guarantee you
I will not be playing like I played it
in 1998 alright this is not ideal this
structure alright so what structure yes
this Bishop the night I'm trying to get
my bishop trip kind of I guess just like
the old guy and then Queen takes so i
protect the pawn that was good that was
good so I'm all about trades all about
trades and so it's like yeah I got the
pawn fork but why doesn't this pawn for
quirk at all what does black simply play
here to swap out the Queen's yes you're
just trading Queens don't be afraid to
ever trade a queen for a queen i like
the
see a lot of people and trade my queen
well if you're just trading your queen
for Queen it's perfectly acceptable I
mean you did nothing gained nothing lost
just go about with the game it's better
to trade queens than to lose a night
like for instance if you like played
Queen back and then took and then you
took you'll be down a whole night but
hey you have your precious Queen okay
good luck all right all right so yeah
just swap out the Queen's all right so
night there of course I'm going to take
it you know alright so now I got a good
night luckily I read Jeremy Simmons how
to reassess your chest in the summer
before the state championship so I know
exactly what to do with my night and
thank God I read it or else I probably
would have just played oh you won't read
the note for the bishop panda I wouldn't
be standing here today re so what move
where do I you or do you think I
ultimately want to get my night to hear
what's a great square for this night
center square all right y'all agree to
center square Saudi for but is that his
end is that his end game all right yeah
we'll keep going to d6 will play out for
first alright so a six so now he's
putting me a test you really want to go
there yes I want to go there alright be
five so so now my night obviously wants
to get the f7 huh I'm happy pretty cool
right but the bishops protecting it
right so how can I try to get that
Bishop off a g6 any ideas yes h4
unfortunately look at what h four runs
into here h5
no yeah and and before anybody says I
think there's no needed castle in this
position my king is awesome and as long
as i don't like oh go right here on the
light squares you know this would not be
good okay because then i just blew my
state championship okay all right but if
you're afraid you're going to you know
do something really really dubious then
fine get castled but you want your king
as we'll see really up in the center
here in these end games okay and look if
your if your opponent only has a light
square Bishop guess what hey let's not
put them on light squares let's put on
my up to then III okay make sense all
right good good good good good all right
so instead of h4 will try to move G for
preparing f5 here okay all right but he
plays that five but how many so so when
he plays f5 here it's a mistake because
we have a tactic this pawn is now
overloaded he's doing too much and he's
not competent okay so so when we take
Bishop takes remove the defender of d5
and we'll take with Chuck everybody see
how that pawn just had too much going
for it after take it couldn't it
couldn't stand up to the pressure
obviously if it takes now Brooke would
just take the pawn so he took what the
bishop takes takes check and now most
importantly what do I have in this
position here a passed pawn excellent
got to be very careful with these past
poems the Good King up so now Chuck
hassle no just get you now I can play
the e2 and I don't have to worry about
getting checked okay so he's like I want
the file so should I just so okay sir
you can have it sorry sorry for being on
that file no
we want that file so we play rook the
other rook to try to control it okay so
rook takes rook takes now g5 okay so
this is a huge move for him all right
because if he take and he takes how am I
going to defend this pawn I can't I'm
done see ya all right so so I protect it
with ft so now he's offering the rook
trade I probably should have thought
about it more maybe maybe Brooke here is
good I just don't know so I thought hey
I got a passed pawn I'm the best let's
just take it and it should be an easy
victory because I got a passed pawn and
he doesn't but I decided to play the
worst move ever playing for Hope Chest
here with h4 hoping that he takes then I
play here here take here take take take
and then I'm the best alright but he's
like I'm better than this and I want my
own passed pawn and I want check so this
would be a great time to slam the piece
and say check and it's like oh man and
now now I'm in a lot of trouble here
alright so I try to create another pass
Pau I say well if I got to pass pawns I
can't lose right alright so it's on but
but it's gonna be tough cuz these Kings
Kings pretty bad and so now I'm not
liking this okay you have to go 4 and 0
to become state champion I'm a senior
because I didn't start playing chess
until my sophomore year so I hope this
is my third crack at state championship
and this is the only time I can do it
right because i'm a senior so three and
a half isn't going to cut it so how am i
going to get one of these pawns the
turn into a queen spicy 5 just Gil hey
you want this passed pawn buddy it'll be
like okay and then you might as well
give them the game one you might as well
get them the other one right and that
would work out very well yeah yeah I've
had as well just uh I'm going to
withdraw anyway so if I don't win so why
not all right so King up to I came back
so c5 so now c5 because now if he plays
here r as we'll see in a minute here so
it's looking like we're just going back
and forth so I got to figure out
something out quick anybody got anything
excellent I gotta get them I gotta get
them up here but first I can prevent him
from coming here what's the only decent
move i have to prevent them from coming
to d7 e6 excellent and now it's like
well I'm either going to win or lose I
love to tell you i calculate it out I
probably did or else I probably want to
play it it but you never know it is you
got to just go for it cuz now Kings
coming in so King to e3 King back so now
do I go or so so we could go back and
forth all day here write and draw right
are
you got to just go for it right bring
the King up because the only way he's
going to turn into a queen as if he's
getting escorted by his King all right
Kenny can you play g3 here yet no cuz
he's I can my king could still catch it
hazen I mean he's in the box yeah so now
play King e5 and now it real I really
should just play e7 now but I don't want
him any chance of him getting to his
King back to e8 to stay me my plans so I
play King up and he pushes that pole
always pushing so fast so nice oh so he
gets a queen but I get the queen with
check yeah check check is so powerful so
he takes and now we got a great check to
win this pawn so now we gotta pass pawn
and so now he's like he's looking for a
check he can't wait to play check so he
finds this check but we have something
excellent to play it's called a yeah a
cross-check and oh so he takes take with
check and then just remove all hope by
taking up that pawn and and so I escaped
with the victory here okay and so now
we're on to Round three and thanks to
the tournament director mr. Bauer who's
been doing this for very long time still
is he does accelerated pairings and then
in round three he d accelerates them
when accelerated pairings are
essentially he gives invisible points to
the top half of the field for the first
two rounds and that takes them away
meaning the bottom half had played other
people in the bottom half in the first
two rounds so there was a lot of people
rated 550 are there abouts 2 and 0 and
in prime position to win the
championship but unfortunately they ran
into a slew of good players and
it didn't work out very well for them so
so this game will try to breeze through
here so we can get to the classic
matchup at the end here alright so flip
the board here so I had the black pieces
against my opponent rated 550 who was to
know he's probably call his mom up hey
I'm all my web halfway there to the
state title so let's see how he does
here all right so far so good I mean now
winning not losing so takes takes big
check g3 just take it why didn't I play
Queen to e4 chuck it could have been
pretty good I just I just can't wait to
take that pawn I guess I just like I
could play whatever I want to play a 550
what do I care all right all right we
got Winston here to witness this all
right thank you for coming Winston and
Wilson alright Bishop takes all right so
so far so good attack my pawn here so I
just eliminate the threat check and now
he's got four pawns and these are
isolated and I gotta you know six ponds
with one isolated so I'm feeling pretty
good castles bishop text so you think
you should play the check of course
right check what do you think I don't
mind that my king is in the center here
I think he's doing okay so Bishop so
he's threatening the discovery here so I
try to challenge the e-file here so okay
so he's got his big discovery in let's
see if it matters rook takes rook takes
I can just take and now when he takes
I got this passed pawn now okay what's a
life is pretty good so okay so
challenged the the e-file again and so
now he gives me this big check King up
h4 rook attacks the pond and King up
check him okay so so notice what he just
played here he just played King to be or
g 2 so what did he just put his King in
the same line as the bishop right so so
this is a very fragile place for this
king so the last thing I want to do is
get that King off of there okay but I
play up anyway alright check but he
stays on the line I can't resist waiting
upon so you were right Winston all right
all right so rook attacks the pawn all
right so I got this whole thing set up
okay so so what move do you think I
should protect this pawn away what what
you got Winston King c5 check doesn't
win anything now you play a five and
then when he plays rook takes pawn check
what you've got excellent and you see
how that's much better than then just
protecting a pond all right so King and
then takes and then the game is
essentially over yes and then you just
take all this stuff and he has to resign
all right
alright and now we got the final round
game the championship game I've got the
white pieces against the defending state
champion here get my my notation right
starts out efore d6 d4 Knight f6 attacks
the pond so we protect it g6 it shove up
Bishop g7 alright so so now we play f3
to prevent this night from ever getting
to g4 and ruining our queen and Bishop
battery here alright so obviously we
play Queen to d2 here and now they play
'if I've alright so bring our night to
protect the pawn here and I castles into
it so obviously what move do we make
that what move have we been leading up
to here yes grassle Queen side all right
our Bishop h6 ya bish of 86 ok you want
to get that as soon as you can so 98
Bishop takes Knight takes and now we hit
Castle queenside ok pawn takes d4 Knight
takes Knight see 5g for all right night
g to e6 and now h4 we want to just porn
storm all our ponds up and get them ok
so Queen to f6 so with Queen to f6 here
he's threatening our night and what else
that's this pawn ok so when I play
Knight c2e2 I'm letting him take this
and well why can't take it now obviously
right or else things would be very tasty
so after
Knight takes remove the defender I
should take back with the the night
which I do alright so so when he plays
Knight to e6 here now when he takes and
Queen takes now Robert has the decision
here should he take the f pawn okay that
leads f pawn make the f line open for my
rooks or should take the Queen and not
worry about getting checkmated over here
any ideas take the Queen all right
there's no right or wrong answer it just
depends on how you assess the situation
you know somebody's going to give me a
free pawn you know I might I might just
have to take it but you know you don't
want to get checkmated so you just take
the Queen's and just say out beach and
the end game so that's what he does okay
so let's check it out here so he brings
the [ __ ] about offering the trade no
trade king to g7 so f 4 h 6 planned out
for might as well play f5 try to break
it open here he retreats I bring my king
up Rick 88 attacks the pawn but it's
protected so Rick f1 here Bishop see six
so he's getting everybody on this pawn
here so now I get a check in all right
check yes excellent alright and he plays
back to 87 here which is pivotal King to
d3 rip the e5
so i protect the pawn some more he plays
g5 so so his ideas with g5 is to get his
King here and here and the back so what
move do I play here you got any ideas h5
it looks tempting to take this huh
because then you get check but then I
just lose a pawn okay frogs are precious
excellent thank you you should you
should be up here co-teaching me all
right so h5 here ok so rook the d8 here
bring my pawn up b6 be for Bishop back
King III DD ate beef up alright so so
now he tries to get he sees that he's
not doing anything really spectacular in
this efile even though he's got all is
all his pieces attacking this I
essentially have three people at
protecting so he decides hey I got to
get I got to get something else opened
here and so he does so what move do you
think you automatically placed he might
even slam it here because it's it's
pretty strong what movie would you slam
here rook takes b5 and that was a joke
all right all right rook 28 right he
just got this whole a file open and now
I want to look on it to do some checking
ok check all right so I'm good all right
that's where they belong all right but I
decided I'm going to be really funny
when he checks me I'm going to put my
bishop in a pin so i play Bishop here
check Bishop there alright so maybe not
the best idea but it got the job done
that way my King gets to stay on this
third rank defending it and and so forth
all right so he decides all right he's
got to find a different way to uh yep so
what move do I played it to stop that
because he is attacking my pawn now yes
King f3 yep king of three is what's
played yes so Bishop to e6 alright so
now he's got a serious attack here does
everybody see what his attack is here
alright so his threat is Bishop takes if
I if I can even waste the move here
Bishop takes and you're like what rook
takes and the rook takes bishop notice i
can't play Bishop takes bishop because
uh because it's Chuck I'm in a pen
excellent okay so so what move do I have
to play here then or else in my whole
position crumbles and I'm not state
champion
excellent work to see one so what i
thought i would play but i played rook
to d1 you see okay I'm that's because
because yeah if he takes and I take my
room I work is protected Brooksie one
also works and you know what every place
worked the c5 I'm like yeah I'll just uh
I like it better on c1 anyway yeah yeah
so so okay so look to be three you see
what he's doing alright so now I go
Brooke see to Bishop to d7 rip the d2 so
I'm max protecting my stuff here my
stuff so work to a three and I bet
everybody's missing a good move i have
here ok alright and i miss it too ok i
miss it too all right well he finally
sees it but but i miss it and and you
missed until I pointed out and so now he
plays I play rook to d5 and he's really
really excited and so he takes here he's
got too much class to slam anything and
now it's like old man I just blew my
whole chance a championship unless I can
do something really really quick here
Winston he found the move for the
comeback Wilson yeah Winston hasn't
found nothing you need to start looking
so it looks like white is in dire
straits here Black is finally broken
through one of crucial pawn my bishop is
in a pin and my Brooke my rook cat oh
you see a check who could possibly check
this king so far
way here 'if I've shack okay so so do
you think when i was playing I'm like
yeah check I'm the best yeah pure
desperation yes yes okay so Robert afore
she doesn't know he's in check cuz I was
like good I just pushed my pulling I'm
I'm in trouble I'm in a lot of trouble
and then so he's like I am going to win
your rook he can't move there but he
touched his bishop right yo oh so where
does this Bishop have to go yeah and so
what do you think I played chef so I
slam that one yeah you slam it's like I
got your bishop alright but the game's
not over yet because now he's like I'm
going to go get that pawn rook out
forward check so if anybody has ever
played poker they're familiar with a
term called tilt it's when you just lost
a big pot or big a big amount of money
or made the wrong play and when your
brain is like that guess what you're
going to make more bad decisions so so
when I was playing check all i could
sell myself as hey dude just keep
yourself in the pin it's going to be
great just keep yourself in the pin so i
kept myself in the pin it's voice oh
yeah i'm making to come back here so now
what move can I make to just end his
dreams here of back-to-back state titles
anybody got an idea yes yeah King the g4
yeah yeah yep yeah yeah because he's
still in it he still in the pen so then
rook takes rook takes pawn takes me five
okay so how would be the only way I
could ever lose this and it'd be tough
but he's got one piece that could do the
trick right this guy trade it off yeah
so what movie we play here Brooke f3
game over right because there's no way
I'm losing this game from here right
alright so so that's a very important
lesson to learn you know if they touch a
piece whether they want to move it or
not if they have a legal move with it
they have to and always enforce it you
can be state champion if you do okay
okay good alright alright well thank you
all for coming and watching a the 1998
Missouri scholastic state championship
you